so today we were welcoming to accomplish
speakers as I said an on Superman II and
Johanna Zhang
both of them have extensive experience
in product management as well as
extensive experience as teachers of
product management they've run a very
successful class here at Stanford for
the past few years and they are going to
be offering it for the first time this
winter to community members local and
remote who want to attend in person or
or online rather than giving an
extensive introduction I'm going to turn
it over to them to tell talk about their
path to product management and then move
into their presentation on the product
lifecycle great thank you everyone thank
you again for joining us today
my name is Anansi Romani like facts
mentioned a little bit about my
background before we jump to the
materials themselves I'm currently the
vp of product called pilots and built
some software to automate bookkeeping
and tax preparation I spent most of my
career after school in product
management itself I did my undergrad in
my grasp of the Stanford if I speak on
home again after I graduated ended up in
product management leadership roles at
companies like Cousteau and Dropbox and
Zynga has been the vast majority in my
career like I mentioned product
management since I left school I'm very
excited to share a little I was learned
today with you so hey guys I am James II
I'm currently a director of product that
we work and before that I was at Airbnb
for four years and I actually met at
Dropbox when we go a lot of vibration
files together in business and then I
started my career in management actually
three similarly similarly
worked in consulting and moved over to
gaming and so that mobile gaming company
called Providence
so that's a little bit about us we
wanted to talk today about to really
large focus areas yeah one of the most
common questions that we get from
students as well as people who are not
p.m. is tell me a little bit about the
job and what does it actually mean one
of the day
they look like I'm potentially
interested in making a career transition
or interested free field especially when
I start out there what is the
responsibility of the product one thing
to note is that our lived experience has
been the job of a product manager can
vary wildly based on complicated company
even in company in similar sectors or
company that seems somewhere from an
outside perspective there are very
different concepts of what it means to
actually be a product manager so we
tried to find some of the patterns in
our class around things we believe are
true across all companies rather than
focus on the fairing and our ticket
there's really four primary jobs of a
product manager at any organization the
first is all about setting the vision
for the product and this is probably
something that many of Yavin suffered
you might have heard the phrase you're
off of the CEO your product I think
that's definitely true and you were
fundamentally picking the fact that your
team has been a walk-on
any early in your career he probably
will not spend a lot of time bigness if
you become a senior product manager
associate product manager but as you get
more senior more and more of your job
actually become this a great example of
what it means to set a vision a lot of
our favorite case studies for the class
is actually Amazon the example that we
give a lot is the company started off by
selling books on the internet but it was
very clear that the founders and the
product leaders knew what they wanted to
do they wanted to be a place where you
can buy anything online and they started
with books and I had a very grand plan
to go from books to everything um so
there's a little bit of a concrete
example to hope to make that real for
you
but one of the things we've seen across
every company and across every industry
is your job as a product leader is to
figure out the vision fair product in
Turkey one thing maybe just add is you
know you have usually a company a vision
I mean maybe I'm organization business
or job can really translate that into
what does it actually mean for your team
and what is your work the second thing
though you seem to be a really common
responsibility across all product
managers about managing some portfolio
of projects begin this transition a
little bit as you start off junior and
become more senior but fundamentally are
almost always
more than flying thing and a big part of
your job is to put together a coherent
set of projects that ladder up to
something for it's not about the next
feature it's not about the next
iteration it's about trying to create
something useful and functional from a
customer perspective for all of the
individual pieces actually connects to
form something larger so we see this a
lot this is another really common
question we get from a life cycle
perspective you tend to do more of this
as well I can get more senior but we
wanted to call it out as one of the four
responsibilities at WCA five the third
one which noticed to be common across
every industry is you actually have a
show stuff it is surprisingly common to
be really good at the first two maybe
less good at this one if you can't
actually build things and deliver things
the customer doesn't matter how good you
are strategy it doesn't matter how good
you are at making projects you
fundamentally haven't delivered anything
of value to your customer so a huge
component of being a product manager is
actually shipping things on time high
quality and well so we'll focus a lot on
this natural class if anybody's
interested in the future about how to
actually ship things on time and how to
deliver products people want but if you
are not actually delivering anything it
is impossible to be responsible process
I think a lot here is shifting is not
just oh we're and on the core project
management right keeping the train
running it's a lot about how do you know
what you want to achieve how do you make
sure that the team cross that finish
line that has impacted everyone and then
finally one of the core responsibilities
of a product manager is all of managing
the product lifecycle there's actually
going to be the focus of the webinar
today it looks like one of the reasons
that a lot a part of the people were
here so I'll turn it over to JD is
introduce the notion of the product
lifecycle and we'll spend a little bit
of time going more detail up Oakland ok
so excited that a lot of you here are
hoping to learn more which I mean is the
point of this webinar today so this
slide basically shows an overview of
what we call the product lifecycle and
so I'll go into each one and talk a
little bit about what does that actually
be and what do you need to consider in
that particular phase of the lifecycle
so overall the cars life cycle is simply
a framework it's a framework we need to
actually take an idea from scratch from
something where it's just a problem for
your users and actually build something
that solved that problem for them one of
the things you want to emphasize here
that our belief is that this is very
much a generic problem-solving framework
that is not specific to a type of home
whether you're making software whether
you're making hardware whether you're a
10,000 person company with your 50
person company they're going to do some
form of this in all stages the amount of
time you spend will vary the amount of
effort you have to put out will vary but
I would not think of this as being
associated with you know a specific sort
of product or a specific flavor of
product management it's a generic
framework for our perspective how to
filter all right so the first where the
product life cycle is called evaluating
opportunities so it's really about
making sure that you understand what
problem you're trying to solve and why
is an opportunity and so there's two
parts to stress the first is you need to
figure out a real need and a problem for
your users and the second part the part
about the opportunity is that you have
to believe that there is an opportunity
for generating value for your business
and so a lot of times we talked about
you know I think at the beginning of the
course he saw something around three
circles right so product management and
at the intersection of you know the
business kind of like the design piece
and also technology so a lot of this is
how do we know that we found something
at that intersection so that on the side
of the user you understand what it is
that they're hoping to accomplish on
this kind of technology you believe that
there's an opportunity and on the side
of the business similarly so technology
believer there's opportunity we really
go deep on this one in a minute that we
introduce the full notion of the
lifecycle unlock every step we spend a
lot of time talking about this
yeah and the reason we do that is the
if you can get anything right it's just
this part because it is the foundation
for everything else in the product
lifecycle and it's also the easiest
thing to actually screw up the second
phase is okay once you have a problem
how do you actually decide what it is
that you need to build and solve that
problem so we call this the dining your
solution we will talk in our class but
not in this webinar about what we call
the design framework where you
essentially really took the diverged in
terms of brain so many different ideas
thinking through what the right design
constraints are in order for you to
constrain the infinite idea that you
could have and then really started
converge right so you know hey what
should I actually put aside my prototype
is cheaply and used my prototype to
identify whether or not I'd look the
most the cheapest MVPs a minimal Minimum
Viable Product in order to solve that
problem yeah and one of the things again
we spend a lot of time on the forest is
for projects of sufficient complexity
there's usually a very large possible
number of ways you could solve the
problem so how do you get the balance
right
which means exploring all the ways to
solve the problem which we take infinite
time will be very expensive and making
sure that you're building the best
possible thing yeah we also talked of
one of that money to know that the
prototype that keeps oh it's actually
good enough passes enough of quality bar
for you to actually understand and it's
something that people would use all
right the next page and it's really much
tied to one on this thing earlier around
shipping is a big part of what you have
to do the next phase is building right
so once you know what solution you
should go you actually need to be able
to guide your team in order to build it
and so as a product manager with
interesting is you actually don't have
any direct lines recording recording to
play on machine so your engineers
reports when engineering manager your
desire for toy design manager how to
actually be motivate them and help them
get to building a product that really
really works and it's beautiful right
and so in in this section we essentially
talk about that iteration of taking
something that's what first time being
able to get it to the point where it is
hardened enough for it to be shipped to
the world and all of the things
in terms of getting getting that
feedback from your different users all
right the next phase is actually
shipping it out to the world and so
right here that's important to note is
that just because you bought it doesn't
mean that everyone in the world can
start using it and so it's actually
really important to understand how do
people start to learn about your
products and with a marketing
perspective how will they start to use
your product how they set the page for
your product and so history is really
littered with lots of examples where
even though someone built an amazing
product it doesn't mean that that led to
them winning the market and so in our
course to talk a lot about what are the
strategies that you can deploy to make
sure that you are shipping and watching
in a way that is thoughtful about
gaining market share
anyone else no one all right
the next phase is measuring so we
essentially have washed it to the world
how do you start to understand complete
up that you're actually solving a
problem that you set out to solve and so
this is really around you know getting
the right information and we're to get
that next phase with a life cycle which
is iteration and so yeah
this is the last piece how do you start
to iterate and create a real feedback
loop where you're taking the book
quantitative and the qualitative data
that you're learning about your product
and feed it back into an actual birth
map where you are able to say okay this
is where we are today this is where we
need to go going back to this concept of
division and the end state here's how
we're going to keep iterating keep
measuring and to get there and I think
what's really important to point out is
what we just laid out for you in terms
of product life cycle is this constant
iterative loop where you're gonna be
running this over and over again as you
work on v2 of your product or even just
a feature and Adams the product design
cool so lastly to stress this is not a
waterfall process I think you probably
refer this terminology before you know
how dog versus landfill all of that the
most important thing to remember instead
of going to detail on definitions is it
means the
where your conflict I can see that
you're constantly challenging your
assumption and you always have in mind
what is it what is it any kind of test
and so it is not something where the
straight line from the beginning stare
all right so again I think to kind of
like turn that into a picture it is a
loop we're essentially designing and
testing constantly and just like an
on-set at the beginning this is
something that should be pretty familiar
to a lot of you I think when we were in
elementary school we learned about know
the scientific method where you have a
hypothesis and test it and so really
that's what this is how do you actually
create a process where you start with a
hypothesis how do you start you test in
an unbiased way how do you have the
right guidance along the process and
then feed that back in to whatever it is
in doing so that you're learning as
you're iterating right so dizzy give you
an overview of the product life cycle at
least our understanding of it and we
want to today is spend a little bit more
time talking about the first piece of
the product life cycle
which is all about evaluating
opportunity and again the reason that we
want to describe what this one is
it is the foundation of getting through
everything else right I very much think
this cumulative process where every step
is dependent on getting the previous
step correct if you get the first step
wrong we can almost guarantee you will
not do the right thing in my career this
is actually been the number one cause
that's see nothing fine wrong where you
don't have a green in ahead at a time on
what you're actually trying to
accomplish you get it three quarters of
the way through building the thing and
you realize that you either are not
solving a real problem from a customer
perspective or the company doesn't have
a life quite frankly let's put off the
beginning and how do you evaluate an
opportunity and what is that actually an
important precursor to evaluating
opportunity it's really important to
have some definition of success and this
is something that ultimately ends up
being personal to you as well as
personal for the company it is okay to
not want to start a start-up is okay to
not want to have a billion dollar
company is totally fine Tuesday my
definition to this is I wish I created a
product that generated passive incomes
like it's been more than I'd like it
this is something that we just want to
end
sighs because there's a lot in the media
particular about pushing you towards a
particular path saying Pat X is better
than how to fly and on taking all this
is very much personal it's all about
knowing what success looks like and
being intellectually honest with
yourself but one of the things we've
seen be really important and you have to
define success upfront as a product
manager sitting in a corporate
environment you need to agree on for
example what the metrics are that
matters the company and what's more
important persons what's less important
and the success look like changing this
by 10 percent or to success have to be
changing it by five hundred percent if
you don't know those things ahead of
time is going to be impossible for you
to figure out what you're trying to
accomplish
so let's talk about the difference
between a problem and an opportunity and
use the word intentionally and
differentiate our view that an
opportunity is idea that validated be
good for both the user and fit for they
come and it's important to be the
intersection of those things so for the
visual people we'll put this up and
apply it where you want to be in the
middle I have a couple of interesting
examples and can illustrate them on one
side of this factor person to each other
I don't know how many people in the
audience are familiar with the recent
startup movie past movie past was a huge
hit where we live because of the
subscription where for $10 a month you
can see as many movies so one of the
amazing things with a single movie in
San Francisco probably cost something
like fifteen to twenty dollars but for
the price of less than one movie you can
see as many let's think about where this
wasn't good for the user versus good for
the climate
this is a great product they had
astronomical growth they had tremendous
word-of-mouth they got a hundreds of
thousands of people to find out for
their product the problem was they lost
money on every single person like
they've done something that they built a
product that was amazing for the user
but was too far to the left on this side
of the spectrum for those of you in the
audience who are familiar with Napster
from 1999 2000 era very similar problem
natcher is an amazing
user perspective independent free music
it turns out to not be a very good
business to run
does an example of how you can be too
far to the left I think one of them is
my personal favorite examples of being
too part of the right is my internet
provider happens to be Comcast for those
of you who accept experience Comcast and
your life I am sorry and they tend to be
really frustrating from a customer
experience perspective and some useful
is perspective you really want to be in
the middle like the whole point of this
and the different unit problem and
opportunity is if you go out and talk to
a bunch of people and hear a problem
back from them it is possible to solve
that problem and still not build a
successful product because you're not
able to capture any infant value for the
problem in each other so today we're not
focused on business models we're not
focused on pricing and packaging well we
at least want to flag up front that you
must be thoughtful not just about
solving customers problems and have to
believe there's some way for you and
your comfortable I would say that a lot
of times at a larger company it's almost
easier to lean on the side of the
company as a booster for user and so
it's really really important my mind
to actually be able to articulate what
is it problem that you're selling user
start there and then say okay you can't
end there we need identity wouldn't do
it for the company what's the
opportunity that I'm talking about but
yes it is happy middle ground kind of an
intersection in this entire Graham yeah
so we talk about what it means to be
good for Jeanne with the final Jubilee
means to get her user there's one pretty
simple means people love your thing um
favorite examples of this are every time
Nintendo wanted a new product for Apple
on Disney product people line up outside
the store that midnight and camp out to
wait to fire thing that's what you want
right it's very clear that you're
generating some real value my customer
perspective if people are demonstrating
that's where people and again what it
means to be good for the company is that
you can capture some meaningful value
and solving the problem and the
unpurchased and they're kind of a lot of
different ways you can do this you can
try and capture a little bit of
a very large number of customers a very
large number of transactions on Amazon
again the great example here they have
very low margins but they sell so much
volume that they're able to capture very
meaningful value you can also be on the
other end of the spectrum you could be
more like or a little more like workday
we have a very small number of customers
if you captured potentially tens of
millions or hundreds of millions of
dollars from episode 4 a lot of them
there's lots of ways to build a
successful business on top of this and
in the class you spend some time talking
about some differences which may be up
to molecule just talked about but
fundamentally your job as a product
manager is to make sure that you start
with a customer problem and then you
believe actually captured by a fund we
talked a bit about the difference in a
problem and an opportunity hopefully you
at least have a loose sense at this
point what it means for something in
opportunity now let's talk a lot about
problem definition and one of the really
common things we see is you start off by
talking dear customer a product manager
goes out in the field they spend a bunch
of time pocket the customers the
customer acts asks for XYZ thing and the
product manager says great they go back
to the ATM and they say we should build
this you were fundamental job as a
product managers often in translate I
want bling from my customer he does the
problem with this approach is it is
fundamentally flawed and it really can
place two key concepts that we want to
talk about today the font face in the
solution space there are many many
examples from both our careers as well
as from history where you go to talk to
a customer they tell you exactly what
they want build that thing and it does
nothing and fundamentally what you're
doing in this world you're delegating
product management to your customers and
very not professional job
there's a little bit of a trope here
that I want to be careful about there's
an epochal for quote that Henry Ford
maybe set and the jury's still out it
might ask people what they wanted they
would have said faster horses and of
course these famous for producing the
first masters for the Model T we're not
saying here is don't listen to your
customers what we're saying is that your
job is to take a stated solution that a
customer gives you translate it back
into a problem and then read the
you're not the right way to solve that
problem and the framework that we use
we're talking about this is called the
problem space and the solution space and
again these are absolutely key concepts
for product management and really the
heart of what we want to indicate today
the problems base is all about where you
talk about what problem you were solving
for the customer it has nothing to do
with how we were going to follow that
off entirely solution economic solutions
based on the other hand requires a
prerequisite understanding of our
problem space and it's all where you
talk about how to solve that problem and
we'll walk through a little bit more
detail and fully make this feel when
let's take the Henry Ford example if
Henry Ford had gone to a customer and
said what do you want and they said a
faster horse what a customer is pitching
is a solution they are pitching a
solution to an unstated problem which is
I wish it took less time to get from
point A to point B your job as a product
manager is to hear the word faster for
us and internalize it actually what
they're wishing for is a different
transit the problem space has no
solutions allowed we're not talking
about fast or anything better anything
how to do any different your only job is
to understand what your customers
believe and feel today is very much a
real mode of listening I'm a huge thing
to emphasize it's about understanding
reality for customers even if they can't
articulate a well and you think it's not
objectively true I have definitely run
into multiple scenarios my career where
a customer believes something that is
not correct
they believe a product of them a certain
feature or that it can't do something
else
it doesn't matter like this is not the
point pitch them out or sell them on it
our job here is to listen and understand
what they believe and understand what
they feel and then figure out later how
to solve it the solutions base is where
you start to introduce the notion of how
we're gonna solve the problem and again
the model that we keep coming back to is
you must talk to your customers your
beginning your customers will model
these two concepts your job is to
distill out of those conversation the
exact problem and then retranslated so
another way of thinking about this is
the problem space is entirely defined by
our
you have zero input here and zero right
to comment on it but the solution space
should be defined by you and if you draw
the clean distinction between that means
your customers are not doing your
product management and you're not
crossing the net and critical eye upon
your customer we know a lot of us can
sound fairly abstract so we want to have
jay-z you walk through an example that
hope they make it's very real very
concrete all right okay so imagine that
you're in a world where your success
criteria it's actually reduce the carbon
footprint of commuting to work and so
you decided hey I'm not gonna small
business I'm gonna take me longer than
50 hours a week and I'm really gonna
focus on this problem specifically
however right and the merry you're like
what you know what one way to do it is
less corns we're by us right and so you
have this concept in your head but
what's the most important time there you
actually go and talk to your users so in
this example you save yourself okay I'm
going to find what my target wants more
actually is this is really important you
need to actually go out and say I am
going to focus on these people and not
these people so your ear and go ahead
and say I'm gonna focus on the people
who play but I'm not gonna focus on
people to take public transport for
example yeah take the subway or take the
bar community or whatever that is so
this is important because if you define
your target user as anyone who might
going back to the previous slide be part
of the the you know solution of reducing
the carbon footprint you would be
talking to a lot of people and you need
to be able to prioritize through time
and then who you're designing for so
okay let's say in this case you're like
alright my hard customer is just are
just the people who buy let me go talk
to them and let me hear what it is that
they're struggling with and so you go
out there and you hear a bunch of
statements that sound a lot like when an
on were just saying were solutions that
customers think they want something and
they were telling you with
think they want those so you go to you
go you go out there you basic here what
I wish I had an electric bike those are
terrible and electric bikes are really
healthy the second thing you hear is you
know I really wish I had a better helmet
because it they're so expensive you know
how their helmet and cheaper I just feel
much more comfortable biking and
therefore I can help you reduce the
carbon footprint the last one is okay I
don't find a lot you know I really wish
would fix the roads Road quality really
really terrible so you know if you did
that then I would come for biking so
let's see these are the three buckets of
theme that you're hearing from your user
when you go out there to ask them why do
you not like as much as you could be
biking or like what could we do to help
you fight more
so it's pretty easy well a lot of times
you have product managers can hear this
and they think that translates into a
solution thingy to fill it's in the
first case you're like Oh someone wants
a much more quiet if only to give them a
cheap usable electrifying maybe they
will actually bike when there are hills
um you might in the case of you know the
next one for the better helmet you I I
just needed to make them a you know
safer one a less expensive one and I did
that to them feel what they're fighting
for but this is kind of the big fallacy
that we're just talking about before if
you just listen to what they said they
wanted and then you built it for them it
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
solving for crux of their problem or why
they're truly not bike in the first
place
so what assume then you're in the
situation and you dig a little deeper
once I'm just hearing what they said and
doing it you start to try and understand
why it is it that they are claiming that
they want a certain situation and
instead you find out something pretty
different than your first reaction so in
the case of the person who's saying but
I really wish an electric bike what
they're really upset about and what
caused them did not want to fight is
that because they because they're a
hills by the time they bite into work
there's actually super sweaty and they
don't have a way to essentially go from
that mode into a insulated
mode where they going to work and so you
actually learn from that user that they
like fighting they get exercise from
biking but because I get so sweaty from
all of my things their reluctance
actually bike so that's a fundamentally
different problem then hey give me an
electric bike and fast if you don't and
won't fight for that person you might
actually find that their they create the
exercise they used to be getting
whenever biking so that's that's why
it's so important actually understand
why they're asking for to think they're
asking for in a second case I actually
learned that the reason my phone was a
better helmet is because they're super
friggin hit by a car so in their mind
one of the best ways to kind of
guarantee that is no protection and
protection to them trampled translate
into health as opposed to anything else
and finally just to go through these
examples and last names for the person
who might be really worried about rural
quality at first blush actually truly
worried about falling they're worried
that with the roads the way they are
they're gonna go through the bus and end
up falling so if you actually understand
the second level of what it is that
they're slowing with you might not very
different solution so the solution that
you would land on instead in the case of
hey you know I really feel like I'm one
of my six legs but you realize that what
they're actually saying is I want a way
to not be super slave I guess work your
solution there could actually be
building showers at work fundamentally
different solution than giving them
electrified in a second user scenario
and where they're asking for a better
helmet but the real problem is that
they're afraid of getting hit by a car
you know a helmet is a reactive thing
it's like happy you get hit by far how
do we make sure that you are you know
not as hard as you could have been
instead of the right solution would be
to build protective bike lanes where
cars can't go into those by plane and
kid divisor and then finally in the case
of the person
I'm falling instead of just fixing the
rust for them
a much cheaper thinking would be
providing them with providing them with
a bike with their suspension you know
think about how much that cost which is
having to repave all your roads that
solution is going to be much more
sustainable and directly solve the
problem that back major is facing you
want to walk through these examples to
just try and make this a little bit real
you know the prior slides can give that
abstract so hopefully they give you some
idea of what we want to talk about today
again we cover a lot of this in the
firefighting powerful mention and really
our goal is to get you a place where
these people who take the course feel
like they're capable and qualified to
either be better park managers they are
already fighting today or confident they
have and solid ratings of rate so with
that I think we'll turn it back over
their hats tax take it away so with that
I want to move into some Q&A we have
been getting really a lot of excellent
questions and on and jay-z and kind of
looking through them there are three
basic categories so I think the first
one building off of what we were just
talking about in terms of the core so
questions around how do you become a
product manager and so maybe just
starting there what would you if you're
say for instance a Enterprise Solution
business analyst we have a very specific
example and you are interested in making
that transition into being a product
manager what advice would you have my
experience was that the unfortunate
reality the best predictor of getting a
product manager job is already having a
product niche having said that though
there are like three or call it common
tasks that probably make up 75 or 80
percent of the people that I speak
entering one of them tends to be more of
an option for a junior people which is
like a structured training and
development program Google is famous for
its APM program yahoo has won Microsoft
ads on Facebook I don't drop one of them
there's a whole set of companies that
happy have a structured program and that
will take people who do not have a
product management background teach them
the skills usually in the order of about
two years and then the
rotated where the company or they go get
a job some wells um that is a usually a
good career option for people who are
earlier in their careers all people who
are transitioning like another way I
should have happen a lot is from the
ends of the business school then they
end up to a rotational program but if
you are later in your career it
obviously has some props associated with
it may not be simplified it one they see
a lot options in that I've seen is have
some fundamental knowledge that about
your customers that is being useful for
product in and the two really common
team that I see transition the most
often in file transfer perspective or
something around like cross summer
success customer support and something
around sales and the reason that both of
those are true because both of those job
fundamentally requires you have a very
strong understanding for customer what
those people can often bring especially
a larger organization is less of the
knowledge about product management
discipline but a very high level of
knowledge about your customers and you
sort of have this interesting pair where
they'll often get paired with the TN
mentor the mentor teacher that person
product management skills that person
makes sure that they had active model
become so if you're interested in that
route obviously depend on your company
about the other thing but making sure
that you can represent a very strong
voice of the customer inside the
building important the last one is a bit
more of a Silicon Valley option so I
recognized that the finest fairly well
everyone but a lot of people who end up
with product managers actually started
companies that either were successful or
we're not successful I'm pretty common
in my experience least of the places
that we worked where
founders of companies and product
management whether through our positions
whether it's through a failed company an
ecto I'm definitely not advocating that
you start a failed company in order to
get a job that's not the most efficient
path to getting there but those three
categories probably make up 80% of the
people that I know in fact yeah I just
do think dad so I know that you
mentioned you're a business analyst
nation analyst I think that having in
that rule actually there's a lot of
knowledge
around the actual fire right you're
actually going in there and they're
saying hey in order for us to deploy
this innovation to work like these
things need to happen and so that kind
of fits into the second one and then on
with describing and I'd sent up to the
last one it's not just about founding
company I think you can also join a
startup right and at a startup it's
there's always too many jobs for the
number of people who are there and so
you get to wear a lot of different hats
and in that case you can wear the hat of
being an engineer but at the same time
where the product hat because you're
essentially you know in a company where
there are product managers and you as it
in here needs to decide you know what is
the problem and how do you actually
employ it and so that's another option
which is not quite the co-founder path
like Buddha was startup and wear a lot
of different hats hats out and then
point back how did you how did you uh so
the way I actually ended up a product
management was I work at a startup as an
engineer and doing what chemical
engineering and process engineering and
I got to pick my title and I just picked
product manager arbitrarily and when I
interviewed of my next role they said we
see you have product man experience and
I said yes so I'm probably the live
example of how not to do it but that
wasn't a total case where the best
predictor of a product management
thought was already having a product
minute that was great I want to build on
something you said and on so you you
said that you see a lot of people
transcend transitioning from customer
success in sales positions I think
there's sometimes a perception that you
need to have a strong technical
background to be a successful product
manager do you have any reflections on
that what level of technical expertise
is that going to depend on the product
or the company or yeah it's going to
depend on a bunch of things for sure um
like if the probability of you
transitioning to infrastructure yeah
it's probably not super high you where
customer support 3 it was a bit role
dependent but the way I thought about
this previously and actually for people
that I've hired is what's not actually
important is some notion of a degree or
explicit credentials in that thing you
don't need a sticky toffee what's much
more important is that you have a
detailed understanding of how the
works and if it's a software product
kind of something fundamental about how
computers work um there are many many
ways to get that some of the best pens I
know actually did not have computer
science training but spend a lot of time
when there are 17 into 22 like building
stuff and taking things apart and
putting them back together there's many
many ways to get that knowledge and one
of the things I see people overemphasize
is like a signaling value of that
knowledge whether it's trying to get
explicitly or something else and my
experience has been it's much more
important to be credible or the team
that is responsible for building
something and that is really the bar
there are many ways to accomplish that
that are cheaper or less time separating
yeah one other things that there is
there are different types of samples
right so you can be a growth PM you
could be more of a generalist yeah you
can be LPM for a lot of you know ml like
work you can be a platform can be an
infrastructure p.m. and for each of
those rules you know the amount of
experience or technical expertise is
going to be different so when I look for
ML OPM having some kind of background in
beta I'm having that experience and
that's a technical acumen is actually
pretty important because a lot of it is
dependent on the fact that you know
you've done this before if you are a
zero to one yeah like a generalist yeah
like actually having a really great
sense of structure thinking of waiting
on problems the most important thing and
so it really depends on what it is the
company piece what is it the product
needs and then for that working through
an area you know what is the match
between the background and identity and
then fun fact I was an econ major but in
the past few years my career so I I do
you know zero to one class but right now
and eat infrastructure so it's a very
different world that the loo editing of
being able to apply some like broad
principles to very technical areas or
vice versa being able to bring some that
a second technical acumen to a growth
area is actually very interesting
so that that's a great segue building on
that where do you see the role of a
class like yours or a shorter class or
webinars if you're trying to become a
product manager where do you what is the
value in that
totally
the first piece of value is I think that
a lot of people actually don't know what
the product management job is I the
number one request I actually get from
students is can we a popping candy tell
me what day it is different than every
company there's a lot of variation in
Maya but one of the things we actually
spent time on early in the class but
what is your job but how are you
measured what success looks like
what is the role and I've actually seen
a non-trivial number of people who
thought they were interested in product
management and actually we're interested
in something else
so being one that I think that the facts
were helpful for is you're not sure
you're interested or you're not really
sure what the role is we will tell you
what there were always at least give you
an accurate if you want to spend five
months for the second part of like what
do people get out of it
my experience has been in much easier to
learn before you have some framework
that you can throw on top of and you can
fill in a fill or examples than anything
else and really what I think the course
offers it a structured way to think
about problem then very few companies
teach most places do not have a program
to teach you product management it is
mostly one job so if you have some brain
work and you end up paying for able to
transition if the role what it doesn't
let you give a month better your job
much faster if you like know how to
think that the broader pattern really
you know the different gene apollomon
solution space that alone will save you
500 hours of 5 500 hours of pain right
there's a lot of things that it sound
like they're small or sound like they're
obvious that you can then have a human
build experience and depth on what you
need to have some framework became that
experience ah ha ha
and he does really well we provide is
some notion of how to think about the
arc of the role a lot of the framework
for people it looks like everybody is
well that's that's great and you raise
the issue and so now I'm gonna ask the
question you you talked about it a
little bit and it sounds like the class
is very focused on this so it's a bigger
question than we have time to fully
answer but we have gotten a lot of
questions about defining that role of
product manager and so let me give you a
few here to kind of make it more
specific do you see the product manager
who's kind of a facilitator you know can
doing all these different pieces or are
they someone who takes ownership of the
product design and then leads the effort
where do you see them in that spectrum
and I know it will depend on the company
but if you can give us some of your
insight into that or your experiences
yeah the people I know who are best at
that job are perceived as facilitators
but are actually decision makers I think
that's like if that is sort of the key
skill that is required
jay-z mentioned this earlier you don't
have a lot of explicit power like you or
not anybody usually or not anybody to
direct manager the routine majority
small or other team like explicit power
is not a way that again and to get
things done but people tend to listen
gene beatific you're right so ultimately
the PM job for me comes down to guiding
the organization to the correct set of
trade-offs to accomplish whatever they
want right we're gonna demonstrate for
the customer and an organization where
you have all the right ideas and what's
missing is like execution or
coordination you can take on a
facilitator role in an organization
where what's missing is the important
ideas but there are very good at
execution you tend to be much more on a
decision painful so I would honestly
think about the role of outcome
backwards instead of skillset forward
it's all about getting outcomes that we
talked about at the webinar and the way
to get there will depend not just on
your company but on your team and even
the people on your like if you have a
world-class engineering manager with
flawless that execution
you should stop spending all of your
time on executions by spending time on
everything else there's a very it's very
fluid in our requires a little bit of
being good at almost every part of the
lifecycle section that we talked about
but I would actively think about
changing your role almost a month from
our third fourth quarter basis based on
whatever is needed to get to the outcome
but finally I was coming to work faculty
yeah I'd say that being a chameleon is
super important and being able to have
the CQ right especially about a
situation be like this is what's most
needed for my sleep and we got a lot
about some core principles we didn't go
into in this webinar in terms of you
know one of the big things that you do
the size and of what an Amish
earlier census yes incentive in
international soil but for the
principles that kind of do everyday we
found a lot in the class about how your
gold is CEO so your subs or the janitor
at the same time which means you know if
there's things that need to be cleaned
up it's your job to clean it up I knew
when you find someone but like at the
end the day the outcome is what's
important so whether you're flexing
between cleaning things or setting the
direction with a CEO role like that's
something you decide it's also really
important that you you are the
facilitator of communication we talked a
lot about life insurance and
communication in twenty mutation how do
you become that kind of like
hub-and-spoke where you're essentially
able to connect all of these different
functions in the organization whether
it's legal or marketing or all these
other roles that need to come together
to shift your product correctly that
makes a man very unique about their role
relative to other roles that are sort of
director a level below is a uniquely
outcome-focused that means i don't
really care how we get there the job is
to get there and you need to diagnose
whatever needs are necessary for
modifications effective this is really
fascinating this is the reason that a
lot of like CEOs and that's coming out
of a fun adventure it is very outgoing
you usually don't have that rendition in
your career until you're pretty senior
like directors and VPS are equally
responsible for the company level but in
most organizations you have to be 15 or
20 years in your career before the
doctors through Friday man one of the
few exceptions to that and that's the
reason that I'm a training ground or
stone ground leader is very executive
because we're really in your career you
figure out what unions know and outcomes
that working that's fantastic
sort of train keeping a little bit on
defining the role but moving into a lot
of the practical questions we got kind
of day-to-day product management
questions one person asked that product
management seems to be very focused on
launching existing ideas or products or
sort of incremental features how do you
recommend that PM's think about the
future is that something that is also
part of your wheelhouse or is that
something that is being decided at a
higher level and so how do you bring
that into your conversation as you focus
on the outcomes that are desired
question any other two different things
I think about one of them it's like
where are you in your PM career if you
have been a product manager for a year
and a half
chances are you're thinking about
through very large macro things or
pretty low usually you're focused on the
next things and explore next week next
month then you get more senior action
attention more into the latter the way
that we strike a balance between them is
a big part of my job as the VP of
Product Management pilot is to make sure
we have the right balance of short term
versus long term stuff there's very much
like a failure mode of product minute
organization where you believe that the
next feature is the Mashable thing right
this is the thing that I'm lost whatever
we're going to accomplish and one of
them is not true so we actually have in
our cover of map setting process a
process that I run where we sort of
classify everything into global
optimizers and global optimizer
the local optimizers are like fears
instead of using the product we have
today we do a bunch of 70 10% other
points that are 50% better but humility
in five years want to be a thousand
percent better we need to make some
bigger bets on things that we for you
can fundamentally change with products
like 2x + 5 X they tend to be more
expensive and it can be much riskier but
I'm really more is like a risk blended
portfolio or I know that we have a set
of small things that I know we're going
to deliver short-term result instead of
bigger thing that actually may or may
not deliver lot but my job is that the
organization's to make sure we can force
it I do think that at all times more
companies your team organization
whatever it is should have a long term
view on what it what it is you're trying
to accomplish and a lot of the PMO's
actually translated like connecting the
dots between all the different levels so
we talked about company level vision we
talked about you know what does that
mean that for a major initiatives across
self and how does that translate into
actual no team and so your job as a team
to break that down so you should have a
you know a year-long roadmap that then
nests into the other thing
the company is going so that any other
point someone could say look all of
these things are happening and we will
come together to get a company from here
this year and so having a long engine is
very important it does depend on a type
of work you're doing if you are growth
p.m. it's actually totally fine that you
don't have a load that for more than
three months out because quite honestly
you're learning every single day in
terms of you know even testing iteration
you're going to learn a lot of things
now that invalidate or validate things
that you do some Ness treat myself but
if you're for example platform p.m. you
matter how many teens won't learn that
because you need to understand how am I
gonna build something where if I do this
the company will be accelerated in the
following way to the platform assist and
so it really depends like the time
horizon that you think out too
depends on the role and kind of where
the company when we're in depends on
father's very strong like a product
manager as a leader and buys here is
fine huh right bro product manager at
Facebook has like a thirty six hours I'm
not going very dependent on the type of
thing that's great so related to that as
you look at and you're making these
these plans how do you strike the
balance between analysis and
decisiveness right what advice would you
have for a product manager or product
team that's facing analysis paralysis or
is moving too fast to actually analyze
anything if that makes sense yeah three
months or what you're testing so that
you can actually say okay according to
that framer this is what I learned and
this is what I'm on and this is what I
want to keep testing and so if you don't
have a framework like that it's really
easy to go down the rabbit hole we're
just like oh crap what should I keep
testing this area like I'm kind of
paralyzed right so most importantly have
a framework and I think in general ins
you said for lots of industries which is
like the 80/20 rule that applies here
how do you actually use
you know data kind of like qualitative
implanted data you have in order to make
some hard decisions and even when it
comes to talking to our users and I'm
talking to thousands of people you
actually usually get what you get with
hundreds of people by just time it's sad
people right so is that 80/20 rule of
five in all things whether it's learning
about your problem time care users or
making decisions on like baby's ass yeah
I have two things they say a lot of my
team one of them is what is the cost of
being wrong second why did you notice
the thing that I've seen actually be the
killer and very large organization with
that everyone it's not that there is
something fundamentally wrong about what
they want to do is that everyone danger
solving slightly different problem or
getting excited my thing
you like disease and end up doing them
right fusion is a huge pillar right now
it's like pretty difficult they had a
hundred people doing the same thing so
as you get larger you end up primarily
coordination problems to solve your
problems actually second was what the
cost of being wrong like and this is a
question I asked a lot in product design
interviews if you have some idea for
something you want to try and across a
team on like a day of engineering great
I don't need to know anymore go for it
seems fine right but if again let's talk
about the tie with a space shuttle or
like an airplane or bridge right the
cost of being wrong is very very large
whether it's you my lives whether it's
five dollar drop something else then you
better be right so I think a lot about
the cost of being wrong and like the
downside of failure or relative the
investment and then I really want them
to notice when your organization is
confused and then we push to where
suffice yeah one principle it's related
to that that TV put the globe visualize
is the conflict of the one-way door
right so like you know if you are
actually going for a door where it's
really hard to kind of back out of be
very thoughtful about that decision but
if you're like look I can be trying it
and walk back quickly that's really fine
that's fantastic we're nearing the end
of our time here so I think maybe we
have time for one more quick question
and then we'll we'll wrap up so another
question that came up several times is a
lot of product teams can have a hard
time saying no saying no to engineering
saying no to the CEO so how do you
especially coming back to your earlier
point that you don't always have
decision-making authority within the
context of the larger company how do you
say no negotiate that's it yeah you know
it is your job as a pianist to say no
but I mean to the point of this question
and Penny say no gracefully and tip that
I usually give my team's is this concept
of yes
otherwise known as provide option and
what that really means is hey look you
know I understand the spirit of what
you're asking for that actually really
employ a lot of times people going back
to it you know users being confused CEOs
can be confused people in the company
you can be they can be like I want this
to happen but really what they're hoping
for is something else really don't
understand the spirit of what it is that
needs to happen translate that into a
problem statement and then say here are
the options that we could go through and
provide we can do a B and C here is the
pros and cons of each one and I as the
subject matter expert and when you're
area really recommend option B for these
reasons and so being able to provide
that kind of like option space and
really have it be back to fight data is
really really helpful in having
conversations the other thing that works
very often is not say no say later and
what's fascinating is like how many
organizational problems for them filled
out we need to say later and it never
comes back the patterns are things we
actually in the building or things that
they keep coming back right like it we
say later and then the Monday and here
in a month later and it like company to
keep coming up then yeah there's Bob is
looking for work on it but you'd be
surprised how many things just go away
if you say yes but later and it's okay
well thank you very much till later but
hopefully in the classroom so I want to
thank you both for your time that was
really a fantastic presentation I want
to thank everyone who attended and for
your questions and your feedback we
really appreciate it again if you're
interested in more from Anand and JZ
there's an opportunity to take a class
with them this winter quarter I
encourage you to check it out and if not
hopefully we'll see you again in some
other
for my there on a webinar or in a
self-paced short course offering so
thank you again thank you another jay-z
thank you everyone for joining thank you
you